لم يحسم جدله اقاله ناظم الزهاوي من منصبه
في الحكومه ومن رئاسه حزب المحافظين مع
تعالي اصوات منتقده للاستعجال في فصله من
الحكومه واخرى معارضه للتاخير في فصله من
منصبه الوزاري رغم الوقائع ثابته
الاسئله تتزايد بشان طرد الزهاوي من
الحكومه بينما يتمسك ريش سوناك بانه تصرف
بشكل صحيح ونزيه بعد تحقيق مستقل في
ملابساته الضريبيه استغرق اسبوع فقط وخلص
الى ان الزهاوي خرق قواعد وزاريه
وما فعلته بمجرد علم بالقضيه هو تعيين شخص
مستقل للنظر في الامر
حس ندى
مؤكده انه اتبع مسار منصفا للتاكد من ان
الحقائق محدده في الملف من جهتهم قال
حلفاء لزهراوي ان لديهم خوف من الطريقه
التي جرى بها التحقيق والذي ادى الى
اقالته المعارضه وصلت توجيه سهام
انتقاداتها الى سوناك مطالبه بالكشف عن ما
كان يعرفه عن وضع الزهاوي قبل تعيينه في
الحكومه في ما قضايا التنمر والتصرفات بعض
الوزراء تلاحق مصداقيه ونزاهه سوناك التي
تعاهد بها لحظه اختياره
مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن